in our morning rounds new evidence that
digital devices can hurt your children's
eyesight the average kid spends more
than seven-and-a-half hours a day in
front of a screen a new study finds
school-age children who spent seven
hours or more a week using computers or
mobile video games triple their risk for
nearsightedness or myopia dr.
Christopher Starr is an ophthalmologist
at Weill Cornell Medical Center in New
York City and he joins us at the table
good morning good morning thanks for
having me so what is myopia myopia am I
saying it my oh my Oh Pia and how is it
in children oh it's very common these
days myopia first of all is
nearsightedness which simply means being
sighted at near so usually the near
vision is okay but the distance vision
is blurry and needs glasses or contact
lenses
conversely farsightedness your sighted
at far but you can't see up close so
those are both very common in childhood
and the RET risk in the rates of myopia
are actually increasing worldwide that
India study that we just talked about
USC study recently just showed that the
rate of myopia in the US has doubled in
the last 50 years in Asian countries
that rate is even higher and as far as
reasons as to why it's yeah not so much
there was one study that found kids
eight and under spent an average of two
hours and 19 minutes a day yeah yeah
between 2 and 8 usually anywhere from 2
to 3 hours a day on screens and the
reason why that's a problem it's not so
much that the device is sending some
magic signal to the eye that's damaging
it it's that when you're on those
devices you tend to be inside and you're
not outdoors in the sunlight and and
interestingly sunlight actually triggers
dopamine which is a neurotransmitter
which actually keeps the eye from
getting too elongated during childhood
so as the eye is maturing if it
stretches too long it becomes more and
more nearsighted so that dopamine
actually prevents that so this isn't
when your mother used to warn you like
don't get right up on a break I know
it's not the same that is one of the
warning signs by the way if a kid is
actually sitting too close to the
television that might be a sign that
they're actually nearsighted and can't
see unless they get really close so that
would be a warning sign and let's be
honest this is sort of the new normal
right we're not going to take away for
sure is
any thing that can be done to help
protect their eyes though with
technology you can put on these screens
oh that's a good question
not really nothing that I know of it's
really just more about limiting the time
and and sort of encouraging them to get
outside in the Sun but the no screen
protector is going to make any real
difference 10 degrees out exactly what
are the signs that parents and teachers
need to be looking for yeah so there are
a few things that and this is a great
time of year to really start observing
your kids they're home from school you
might be off from work as well so things
like squinting if they're squinting to
see things like that's a good sign that
there's a problem if they're sitting too
close to the television or thered if
they're holding their digital device
right here that's a problem but other
things like attention like if they're if
they used to be very much interested in
reading or drawing and all of a sudden
they're not that interested in it or
they're reading they keep losing their
place online those are signs that there
might be a vision problem and some of
the learning disabilities like ADHD and
dyslexia and things like that are
sometimes miss attributed to those
things rather than a vision problem that
is causing the kid to not be able to
learn learning is 80% visual if you
think about the way we traditionally
learn looking at boards reading homework
you need good vision to to learn and as
you said great time now when the kids
it's a great time to really sit there
and look at the factors that are in the
pocket very much thank you very much
that's right